I feel like tonight went pretty well for
you guys I mean Carrie Anne said one of
the best male rumbas she's seen how are
you feeling
that's a huge compliment because we've
had some amazing dancers on the show so
that is one of the biggest compliments
you can get from carrion
I mean it really meant a lot we
struggle I mean I struggled with this
dance a little bit and it was it was a
hard one but I'm just so freaking happy
with the results and and what this dance
meant to me and so I'm just filled with
joy right now well and you we're very
open about you know sort of forging your
own path and we even saw you get a bit
emotional towards uh after the dance I
mean what did it sort of feel like to
sort of share your story tonight
I mean it means a lot to me the song
meant a lot the dance meant a lot and
just uh giving that sending that message
across
um not just for me but for anyone in
general there's there's so many people
out there that that have these
accomplished parents these accomplished
family members brothers sisters you name
it that they always feel like they get
compared to that they always feel that
they need to chase that they need to
beat and uh and so this year means so
much to me because this is the year that
I really figured out that I don't need
to live up to anyone's expectations I
don't need to beat anyone I need to beat
myself I need to live up to my own
expectations and that's the message that
I wanted to get across is do it for
yourself don't do it for the
expectations that other people have on
you and you know it's Chase Chase your
own dreams and that's what I'm doing
that's what I want to share
okay
um you know and also this week you guys
have to do multiple dances I mean how
are you feeling and what can you tease
about tomorrow night I don't know
this week was overwhelming we had to
learn four new dances because the other
two that were performing tomorrow we
have never danced so It's Tricky but
he's been a good sport he's been showing
up to rehearsals wanting to do better
and better so
it's been a good learning curve
um tomorrow he's taking me to my first
prom I've never been to prom and we are
doing a spicy Cha-Cha spicy
emphasize the word spicy
I also have to ask
how do you think he'll do are you
excited about next week oh my gosh I
can't even think about next week right
now it makes me kind of anxious so try
to take it week by week but I'm excited
to meet him I'm excited to see what he
has to say for to everyone and his
comments and stuff so yeah it'll be fun
love his music yeah I mean it'll it'll
be fun I I love Michael Buble he's he's
an amazing artist and uh you know we
have a we have a great song coming up so
it'll be it'll be really fun okay um and
then lastly I have to ask about Selma I
mean what do you think uh you know how
much has she touched everybody at
Dancing with the Stars and what do you
think the impact she's left on the show
has been yeah
a huge inspiration to everyone just a
good human being she's a very rare
person it's very rare you meet someone
at her level of Fame
and how humble she is so it's she's just
an incredible human being and we are so
lucky to have met her and call her a
friend so thank you so much I mean huge
inspiration I keep saying it over and
over again that she is just a light in
every room that she walks into and she's
such a has such a warm heart and spreads
her love everywhere and so you know I've
Loved getting to know her and you know I
really am glad that I gained a such a
great friend in her through this
competition and you know we're gonna
miss her here seeing her at rehearsal
senior here in the ballroom it's it's
sad to see her go but of course we
understand the circumstances and and uh
you know I'm just so happy that she's
inspired me she's inspired so many
people that have been watching the show
throughout